every Christmas Eve certain traditions
say that Santa has just one night to
deliver presents to millions of children
around the globe now this might seem
unreasonable from a scientific
perspective but we wondered exactly how
unreasonable is it overall it's
difficult to determine how many people
around the world celebrate a Santa
centric Christmas on December 25th but
if we consider certain religious and
cultural traditions we get a rough
estimate of about 600 million people now
let's say each household has on average
two and a half kids so santa only needs
to visit 240 million homes even better
he is more time to get the job done than
you might think
legend has it that he drops by when the
kids are asleep so that gives him eight
hours right well hold up we mustn't
forget about time zones
there are 24 broad time zones worldwide
each one hour apart so factor in the
different Christmas Eve start times
across the planet and kringles got a
luxurious 31 hours to make his
deliveries unfortunately this is where
his luck runs out because just to reach
every house he'll have to fly 1200 times
faster than the world's fastest jet
fighter that's a lot to ask of nine
reindeer which can only gallop up to 80
kilometres per hour on average way too
slow but to be fair that's the best they
can do on the ground since we don't know
exactly how fast a reindeer can fly
let's assume they can manage those
incredible speeds even then the load
they have to lug is much too heavy for
them if every kid receives a single
mid-sized lego set the bag alone would
weigh a whopping 600,000 tons or about
20 Statue of Liberty's meanwhile the
average reindeer can pull up to twice
their weight or about 200
25 kilograms so those deer aren't going
anywhere
and even if they could well it wouldn't
be pretty
for starters the team would create a
massive sonic boom
as they hurtle through the air at 3,000
times faster than the speed of sound
deafening any bystanders on the ground
below
Merry Christmas folks but it gets worse
once Rudolph and Co take off they
vaporize before they reached their first
house just like how a rocket heats up
when it reactors the atmosphere at
tremendous speeds the reindeer would
heat to blistering temperatures that
would turn them into venison jerky and
Santa wouldn't fare much better because
he's sitting on what amounts to the
worst rollercoaster ride on earth when a
typical coaster accelerates you get
pushed back against your seat but in
Santa's case to accelerate to those
extreme speeds makes for a much stronger
push a force tens of thousands of times
stronger than gravity would pin him to
the sleigh smashing his bones and
internal organs to jelly but it's not
all doom and gloom let's assume Santa
and Friends miraculously survived this
ordeal he slips his conveniently
boneless body through chimney after
chimney drops off the gifts and now gets
to munch on his well-deserved treats a
lot of treats if every household offers
him three sugar cookies and one 8-ounce
glass of whole milk that's 720 million
cookies and enough milk to fill 23
Olympic swimming pools total now that
adds up to three hundred ninety six
billion calories plenty to see him
through his hibernation until Christmas
comes round again
[Music]